we're asked to divide and we're dividing
6 plus 3i by 7 minus 5i and in
particular when i divide this i want to
get another complex number so i want to
get something you know some real number
plus some imaginary number so some
multiple of i so let's think about how
we can do this well division is the same
thing and we could rewrite this as 6
plus 3i
over
7 minus 5i these are clearly equivalent
dividing by something is the same thing
as a rational expression where that
something is in the denominator right
over here and so how do we simplify this
well we have a tool in our tool kit that
can make sure that we don't have an
imaginary or a complex number in the
denominator and that's the complex
conjugate if we multiply both the
numerator and the denominator of this
expression by the complex conjugate of
the denominator then we will get rid of
or we will have a real number in the
denominator so let's do that so let's
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by the conjugate of this so
7 plus 5i
plus 7 plus 5i is the complex conjugate
of 7 minus 5i so we're going to multiply
it by 7 plus 5i over 7 plus 5i and
anything divided by itself is going to
be 1 assuming that you're not dealing
with 0. 0 over 0 is undefined but 7 plus
5i over 7 plus 5i is 1. so we're not
changing the value of this but what this
does is it allows us to get rid of the
imaginary part in the denominator so
let's multiply this out our numerator
our numerator we just have to multiply
every part of this complex number times
every part of this complex number you
can think of it as foil if you like
we're really just doing the distributive
property twice we have 6 times 6 is
or sorry 6 times 7 which is 42
and then we have 6 times 5i
6 times 5i which is 35 sorry 30i plus
30i and then we have 3i times 7 so
that's plus 21i
we plus 21
plus 21i and then finally we have 3i
times 5i 3 times 5 is 15 but we have i
times i or i squared which is negative
1. so it would be 15 times negative 1 or
minus 15. so that's our numerator and
then our denominator
our denominator is going to be
well we have we have a plus b times a
minus b you could think of it that way
or you could just do what we just did up
here actually let's just do what we did
up here so you don't have to remember
that difference of squares pattern and
all of that
7 times 7 is 49. let's think of it in a
foil wave that is helpful for you so
first we did the 7 times the 7 that we
could do the outer terms 7 times 5i is
plus 35i then we can do the inner terms
negative 5i times 7 is minus 35i these
two are going to cancel out and then
negative 5i times 5i is negative 25i
squared negative 25 i squared is the
same thing as negative 25 times negative
1. so that is plus 25. now let's
simplify them these got these guys down
here cancel out our denominator
simplifies to 49 plus 25
is 74.
and our numerator we can add the real
parts so we have a 42 and a negative 15.
so see 42 minus 5 would be 37 minus
another 10 would be 27 so that is
27 and then we add and then we're going
to add our 30i
plus the 21i so 30 plus 21 30 of
something plus 21 of that's of an of
that same something is going to be 51 of
that something in this case that
something is
the imaginary unit it is i let me do
that in magenta i guess that's orange so
this is plus 51i
and i want to write it in the form of a
plus bi the traditional complex number
form so this right over here is the same
thing it's the same thing as 27
over 74
27 over 74 plus
plus
5 plus 51
plus 51 over 74
plus 51 over 74
plus 51 over 74
times i and we are done i want to write
that i in that same orange color
and we are done we have a real part and
we have an imaginary part and if this
last step just confuses a little bit
just remember this is the same thing if
it's helpful for you we're essentially
multiplying both of these terms times 1
over 74. we're dividing both of these
terms by 74. we're distributing the 1
over 74 times both of these i guess is
one way to think about it and that's how
we got this thing over here but we have
a nice real part and a nice imaginary
part